today on the matt wall show leftism is a
religion of self-loathing
that's what it is and this has been made
i think very clear this week especially
as white people across the country have
gone out of their way to announce and
advertise their white guilt
but the self-loathing issue goes way
beyond race we'll talk about that today
also five headlines including
uh attorney general barr revealing and
antifa's role
in the riots and in our daily
cancellation we will cancel
a maniac who went on cnn to announce
that white children quote
don't deserve innocence and so he
believes that
white parents should intentionally rob
their children's innocence
as a way as a show of racial solidarity
so we're talking about all of that
coming up
but starting here one of the things we
have seen this week
and uh for the past many years and
decades really is that leftism
is a religion and specifically a
religion of self-loathing
now this may seem counterintuitive at
first because leftism
would appear to be a religion of
narcissism religion of self-worship
really
the two things narcissism narcissism and
self-loathing actually are not mutually
exclusive at all they go hand-in-hand
i would say on the contrary they
necessarily go hand in hand in fact
the definition of narcissism according
to dictionary.com anyway
is selfishness involving a sense of
entitlement a lack of empathy
and a need for admiration as
characterizing a personality type
well who does that sound like to you
that is leftism to a t
of course and there's nothing about it
that precludes
self-loathing you know narcissistic
people are quite often very
self-loathing
and their obsession with hating
themselves and finding affirmation
and assuaging their sense of guilt
trying to feel better
about themselves trying to get other
people to like them trying to get other
people to recognize
their virtue and how great they are that
is all narcissism
now if you don't believe me that leftism
is a religion of self-loathing then
let's just review
a few of the incidents from this past
week or two
some of these we've talked about played
some of these clips already individually
on the show
but i want to recall them again and then
we're going to get to the
kind of like the grand finale of white
guilt and white and
white self-loathing so you want to stick
around for that but
what we've seen you know aside from the
rooting and the
writing and the looting and the anarchy
and chaos and everything are many videos
of white people debasing themselves
humiliating themselves
in this desperate attempt to prove
that they are not racist and and i
should say a futile attempt because it
doesn't matter
they're still going to be seen as as
racist that's part of the racial
narrative
uh the ideology of leftism is that white
people are racist no matter what
we're racist inherently and in fact if
you say you aren't racist that's more
that's just more proof that you are
so it's not going to work but this is
what they're doing
um let's um play a couple of these again
we played this on tuesday this is a
group of white folks
literally kneeling before a group of
black people
and apologizing for racism
we're not shaming anybody guys we're
just opening ourselves before you
yes lord you brought the thunder and
rain today god
because satan takes the hell today
father in jesus name you get the victory
father
we ask for forgiveness from our black
brothers and sisters for
years and years of racism nothing creepy
about that at all
and then we played this yesterday this
is uh some white people on their knees
in some cases and or sitting down hands
in the air
repeating every word that a black lives
matter activist
tells them to repeat
about racism anti-blackness or violence
i will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
and do everything in my power to educate
my community
i will love my black neighbors the same
as my white ones
and can i just say one other thing when
you watch these videos
especially the first one of the white
people kneeling you know
if if i would be very uncomfortable
uh not just as the person kneeling or i
just i would
i simply wouldn't do that but if
somebody was kneeling to me
doesn't that make you really
uncomfortable isn't that super
awkward and i say that as a theocratic
fascist
now i say that as somebody under my
regime everybody will kneel before me
but what i'm saying is because of my
incredible humility
i will be very uncomfortable with it i'm
gonna require it at gunpoint if you
don't know you'll be killed but
it it it will hurt me more than it hurts
you is what i'm trying to say
all right um and uh now here this is
just very sad and infuriating but here's
a
and i've got more about this in this
vein during the daily cancellation but
here's a white
parent who forced their child to kneel
and hold a sign
confessing her white privilege this is
the picture um
and that's child abuse right there
imagine indoctrinating your your your
own what four or five-year-old
child into feeling guilty about their
race
how sick and perverted do you have to be
but like i said we have more about that
in the daily
cancellation and then there's this video
maybe you've seen it it went pretty
viral and it shows a guy
telling a woman to kneel and apologize
to him for her white privilege
there's a lot more to this which we'll
play in a second but here's here's the
video that's going
viral all over the place excuse me
hey excuse me i work for black lives
matter
i'm sorry i work for black lives matter
i'm sorry that i scared you
but since i work for that company my ceo
has told me to come out today
and to bring you on your knees because
you have white privilege so if they see
that a white person is getting on their
knees that shows solidarity for
the situation the situation
and could you just please apologize for
you know for your white privilege
just apologize i am trying to think of
the right words to say because that's
a big thing to say
you know with this country we have that
president donald duck
that clown in office you know he's
brought a lot of bigotry and you're not
a part of it right
no and so you know
just letting you out okay you have a
great day
okay now that looks pretty bad doesn't
it
trust me it gets a whole lot worse
and uh i'll i will play the rest of that
video for you in just a second but
before we do
you know rockauto.com great sponsors
great friends of this show
uh and uh we really appreciate them not
just to sponsor the show but as a great
company because if you're looking for
auto parts
if you're looking to you know if you
have something on your car that needs to
be fixed
no reason to go into the auto parts
store uh just go to rockauto.com it's so
much easier they're always offering the
lowest prices possible
rather than changing the prices based on
what they think they can get out of you
so this is not
you know a lot of times when it comes to
car stuff you have to worry about that
but you don't have to worry about that
with rockauto.com rockout.com is a
family business
honest business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices
at rockauto.com are reliably low and
they're the same no matter who you are a
professional a do-it-yourselfer
they're gonna offer you the lowest price
they possibly can the rockauto.com
catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate listen i've
been on rockauto.com many times
if it's easy for me to navigate then it
will be a breeze for you
okay go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car
truck write walsh
in there how did you hear about usbox so
that they know that
we sent you all right now
played you the clip that clip is
actually from a 45 minute video
a live stream done by a youtuber who
goes by the name of
smooth sanchez and he's actually not
black but he's he's
hispanic um he goes around new york city
for 45 minutes during the the protests
in the writing
and he tells a whole bunch of white
people not just that woman to kneel
on command and most of them
the vast majority do exactly what he
says
immediately and without question he goes
up and says kneel and they get on their
knees
now the guy smooth sanchez
i don't know if that's his christian
name or not but uh he's obviously
trolling okay he's not this is not him
being sincere
so i don't think he's the bad guy here i
think actually he's exposing these
pitiful self-loathing masochists
and in that way he's performing a
community service
but so let me i i pulled a few more
clips from his video
that i want to play for you and there's
a lot more where this came from but
uh here's just here's just a a taste and
this is probably all you could possibly
stomach
excuse me could you take a knee for
george foreman the guy who just died
recently to police brutality
i'm with black lives matter and i just
want you to take a knee like
colin kaepernick please i work with that
foundation could you just take a knee
from me right quick like this like just
yeah it's good just take the there we go
excuse me
wait are you joaquin phoenix no
okay um i work for black lives matter
and it would be an
honor if you were to please take a knee
for the man that just died
the this past week i'll do it
but it's gonna be really painful because
i just had knee surgery
so you know i i just had i just had i
just but i will do it
for the cause okay
okay that's good and so you respect the
black lives matter movement i understand
yeah can i get off my knee now it really
hurts
okay all right i would just like it if
you get on your knees
for to show you show that you're not
you're against your white privilege
because you guys are
privileged and um just please apologize
for
you know because when you take a knee it
not only represents
what colin kaepernick did it deeper
represents
um what that officer did to that poor
man
what he did to george foreman is is is
not okay
and i think you could agree with this
absolutely yes
so could you always apologize for your
white privilege
you know we we can't speak on behalf of
what everyone else
is dealing with it's not a white human
being but
right all we can say is that we
support the movements that are going on
the non-violent ones and
we you know we took in a peaceful
protest yesterday but you know you guys
should be guilty because it was a white
man so you guys
are do you feel guilty and part
you're you're an accessory to allies
absolutely
first of all i think that this is a very
important video
in from an academic sense i think
anthropologists of the future
are going to want to watch that video to
try to understand
what happened to american society
i mean that video is not going to answer
a lot of questions it's going to raise a
lot of questions but
it will be an important piece of the
puzzle i think
and those women at the end there did
they really just did i hear that right
they they agreed that they are
accessories to the murder of george
floyd because they're white
they agree they agreed with that
statement and notice of course he
repeatedly says
george foreman instead of george floyd
and many of the white people don't even
correct him
because they're afraid of being called
racist then the other guy who just had
knee surgery
and and he kneels on the concrete and
he's in pain and he does it anyway
because he doesn't want to
say no to the guy now of course the
correct response when someone runs up to
you and tells you to kneel for them
is two words and the first word starts
with f and the second word starts with o
or maybe the second word start with y
you know either one of those
alternatives will work
or something in that vein i mean that
that is the correct response when
someone says
kneel on the ground um but leftism again
is a religion that teaches people white
people to hate themselves to be ashamed
of themselves
when in reality of course nobody should
hate themselves for
their race nobody has any guilt just
because of their race
this should not need to be said this
should not be controversial
nobody owes anybody else an apology just
based on their race nobody
nobody is responsible for oppression and
persecution or any bad thing
at all just because of their race
again shouldn't need to be said but it
does it very much does
and let's go further and speak
specifically here about about you know
white people and the white race
um you know
no individual white person is
responsible for whatever sins his
ancestors committed
nor does he owe an apology for them
nor can he apologize for them an apology
for something you didn't do
is uh not only pitiful and pathetic but
it's
completely pointless it's
it's and toothless
you can't apolog what does that mean i'm
gonna apologize for something that
someone did
300 years ago okay what does that mean
um and furthermore
whatever sins a white person's ancestors
may have committed
slavery murder rape oppression theft of
land
um and whatever it is
and yes it's likely that every white
person has ancestors who did
that sort of thing but none of those
sins are unique to the ancestors of
white people
all of those things all of them were
commonplace
all over the world and still are so when
i say that it's
almost certain that every white person
has ancestors who did that
that's just because it's almost certain
that every person
in the world has ancestors who did that
stuff
the only difference being that slavery
is abolished in the west now while still
practicing other parts of the world
but going back in history slavery was
institutional
everywhere for thousands of years
violence and brutality these were the
way things worked
everywhere if you wanted land anywhere
you you took it and if you wanted to
keep your land anywhere you had to
defend it
the world was a brutal place for a long
time it is only slightly less brutal now
and it also depends on where you live
so the idea that white people are solely
or uniquely responsible for
any of this stuff is nonsense
um but i talk about leftism being a
religion of self-loathing
um and you might say well it's not
because what if you're not white
then you're not being told to hate
yourself well the problem is that the
self-loathing doesn't just apply to
white people it goes way beyond race
okay this is an issue that extends way
beyond race and we'll talk about
how far it extends in just a second uh
but first
a word from uh some relatively new
sponsors on the show who we really
appreciate
uh and that would be bambi you know
having a good hr department
i think is crucially important at all
times especially now
with all the challenges in the world
when running a business you know hr
problems can kill you wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations is very
complicated
there are a lot of land mines that
you're walking over there and hr manager
salaries are not cheap either an average
salary is
70 000 a year for hr uh bambi spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e was created specifically for
small businesses you can get a dedicated
hr manager you can craft hr policy
maintain your compliance
all for just 99 a month with bambi
you can change your hr from the biggest
liability you have
one of your big expenses to your biggest
strength
uh and on top of that it's very
affordable your dedicated hr manager is
available by phone email
real time chat i mean this is someone
who works for you uh
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time there's no reason not to
do this
i think you can't afford uh to not do it
go to bambi.com
walsh right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com
walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh
okay so the religion of self-loathing
goes way beyond
race you know leftism yes teaches white
people to hate their race
it also teaches men and boys to hate
their sex
uh hate it so much that they literally
mutilate themselves
in a vain attempt to change it it
teaches women to hate their femininity
to hate it so much that in some cases
they go out of their way to be boorish
and crass
so as to be more like men or at least
more like the cartoonish idea of men
that feminists have in their heads it
teaches americans to hate their country
it teaches free people to hate their
freedom it takes
teaches independent people to hate their
independence
the things that are most natural
and and good and healthy in you and
about you
the things that are most fundamental
most elemental most
unchangeable those are the very things
you are taught to hate
those are the things that you were
taught to try and change even though you
can't
meanwhile the things you should hate
about yourself
the things that you can and should
change
you know say your crappy personality
your vanity your selfishness your sense
of entitlement
your unhealthy lifestyle those kinds of
personality defects
those are the very things you are told
to accept and love
those are the things you're told you
cannot change immutable
characteristics so a man should hate his
masculinity
and seek to become a woman to change it
but for example an obese person should
love their obesity
and accept that it can never be changed
this is the the dichotomy that you get
from leftism
and that is why it is a contemptible
toxic
noxious poison
by the way before we get to headlines
one other point about this
that i was thinking about when you watch
that video of the
white people falling to their knees and
there's another example of this too that
i you know i i wasn't getting
very much into on the show because i
don't know how real it is but
trending on social media this morning
was the the hashtag
um baldfordblm
and the idea is that you're supposed to
shave your head white people are
supposed to shave their heads in
solidarity with the black lives matter
movement
which makes no sense of course now i am
99.9999
sure that this started as a like a 4chan
hoax where they're trying to get dumb
white people to do this to embarrass
themselves
uh but it did manage to trend i'm not
sure
how many people actually did it for real
there were a lot of posts
of especially white women showing off
their bald heads
i think a lot of that was fake i mean
people trying to get others to do it
which i really appreciate i mean don't
get me wrong
the hoax i really appreciate i think
it's great um
i'm not sure how many people really did
it sincerely although based on that
video we played
it does it wouldn't surprise me at all
if a lot of people did it and
the poi the point is or at least another
point you know when you see that video
you see all this
uh for for these white liberals
the worst thing in the world that could
ever happen to them
is that some people think they're racist
that for them they would they would take
anything over that i mean they would
prefer
for you to see them in any other way
than that
if they had to choose between one person
thinking they're racist
and everybody in the world thinking that
they're serial killing cannibals
they would take the latter in a
heartbeat in a heartbeat they would
prefer for everyone in the world to
think that they're serial killers and
cannibals
than for one thing person to think
they're racist and in fact
um if if they could get you to believe
that they were
racially woke cannibals who only kill
the nate white people
that they might actually prefer that
they might see that as a net positive
they might actually try to cultivate
that brand
who knows um but the point is
for them it's the worst thing in the
world to be thought of that way
even for a ridiculous reason and that's
why
they so often in an argument with you
will throw the word racist at you rather
than presenting an argument they'll just
oh you're racist
and they think it's a trump card they
think that will shut you down because
for them if it was them it would shut
them down
they will do anything to avoid being
called that
and so they think other people operate
that way so they think
you're presenting an argument they have
they have nothing to say in response to
it so instead they say you're racist
and what they expect you to do is say oh
no no i'm not racist please please stop
don't call me that
whatever you want whatever you want
you're right you're right just that's
how they expect you to respond because
that's exactly how they would respond
and then when you don't that's when they
get very flabbergasted
they don't understand what's it hold on
a second how is this not working
what they don't understand is that for a
lot of us
you have so misused and misapplied and
abused this term
that it doesn't mean anything anymore
when you call somebody racist
it could be that they're actually racist
i mean there are racist people out there
but you know 90 of the time with the way
that it's used you're you're talking
about someone who's not racist at all
they just have an opinion you don't like
and so for a lot of us for a lot of us
normal people we just don't care anymore
whatever label you want to throw sexist
racist homophobic transphobic
whatever it doesn't matter the label has
no meaning
at all anymore it has no effect
this is a weapon that you wield that is
only effective against you
it's like it's like superman trying to
use kryptonite on somebody else
sorry that doesn't work you're gonna
need something else
because uh that that that's a weapon
that only that weapon gets you not
us um and that's your own fault
you know if if you hadn't misused the
word racist so much
then uh you know it would it would have
some meaning still
and when you called someone racist there
would be some real power to that charge
but uh there just isn't any more
let's go to news headlines number one
joe biden was talking to don
cheadle for some reason and that's when
he shared his
true thoughts about the american people
listen
we'll have to address these issues
straight on
and the words the president says matter
so when a president stands up and
divides people all the time
you're going to get the worst of us to
come out the worst in assault to come
out
this president's talk constantly talks
about
equality without without lecturing talks
about
and has administration that looks like
the country and the rest it changes
attitudes
and it's about the attitude of the
country do we want our kids do we
do we really think this is good as we
can be as a nation
i don't think the vast majority of
people think that they're probably
anywhere from 10 to 15
of the people out there they're just not
very good people
but that's not who we are the vast
majority of people are decent
we have to appeal to that and we have to
unite people
bring them together bring them together
10 to 15 percent are not very good
people
now the thing is he's right of course
probably way more than 15 percent aren't
very good people
uh the idea that everyone in the country
is fundamentally decent
and good is silly of course and childish
and clearly not the case
but i think now i think biden is
singling out the wrong 15
also politically of course this is a
boneheaded thing to say
there's just never a time when it's a
good idea for a politician to say that
any percentage of americans
aren't good or decent there's no
there's no winning there when you say
that uh even if it's clearly true and by
the way if we're if we're listing groups
of people who aren't good and decent
we should obviously start with
politicians joe biden included
we should start there and then and then
we can branch out from there
number two foxnews.com reports several
members of the minneapolis city council
this week have expressed support for
radical changes to how the city handles
law enforcement including a move to
dismantle the police department and
replace it with a transformative new
model
for public safety and so we're hearing
about this dismantling the police
defunding the police according to the
daily wires celebrities like
megan rapinoe uh john legend lizzo
have signed a letter demanding that
police departments be defunded
and i think that's very interesting
because you've got these wealthy
celebrities who live in gated
communities
and got personal security and so they're
good to go
they're surrounded by armed security all
the time they've got the gated community
they've got the gate around their house
the armed
guards and everything and so they're
fine
what they're saying now is yeah get rid
of the police department for these
neighborhoods and
and these these people who are in
dangerous neighborhoods they don't need
it we can get rid of it for them
they'll be fine very
very courageous right very courageous
perspective from these
people number three tony dungey's former
nfl head coach super bowl winner
nfl analyst now was on a sports talk
show
this morning and he was asked about the
drew brees situation
drew brees like we discussed yesterday
came out and said that people should not
disrespect the flag that a bunch of
insane crybabies
freaked out about it and drew brees uh
apologized to them speaking of
self-flagellating white people
brees basically took a knee uh crawled
on his hands and feet and said please
forgive me i'm not racist
anyway here's tony dungy's take on this
who has to have those conversations you
think tony who who
we all have to have we and we have to
have drew brees
saying what he said i don't i don't
downgrade drew for that okay that's what
he said
he may not totally understand it may
have been uh not exactly the way he
wanted to express it but he can't be
afraid to say that
and we can't be afraid to say okay drew
i don't agree
with you but let's talk about this and
let's let's let's
sit down and talk about it we can't just
say anytime something happens that we
don't agree with hey i'm done with that
and i'm done with this person and that
doesn't make sense uh
we we have to be better than that this
battle is not going to be won
by demonstrating and throwing bricks
through windows
it's not going to be won by the the
government saying hey we're going to
bring out these weapons and dominate the
streets again
that is not going to fix anything the
only notable thing about that
about what tony dungy said there is that
it is notable
it's it's notable that something like
that is notable these days because what
he's saying is
in reality basic common sense
obviously correct obviously the most
sensible and ethical and intelligent way
of approaching this
he's saying hey if we have a difference
of opinion let's talk about it
if somebody expresses an opinion about
the flag or a protest
rather than crying and freaking out and
panicking
why not talk to them and say why do you
feel that way
let's have a discussion and oh by the
way don't throw bricks in people's
windows that was tony dungy's message
and it becomes this this headline thing
and it goes viral it's all over the
place
because it's so rare to hear especially
on national tv
from a prominent voice to hear basic
common sense
although from tony dungy it's not rare
he's a really common sense guy
uh big tony dungy fan um i think
everybody is tony dungy's one of the few
i was asking this the other day can you
name like
i don't know five americans who
everybody agrees
is respectable and decent and admirable
you know i i think in times past
almost all americans could agree on a
whole host of people who they consider
to be sort of
admirable figures but these days things
are so political
and ideologically divided everything
becomes political that there's almost
nobody left
who everybody admires i think tony dungy
is one of them
who else
is there anybody has it just tony dungey
there's got to be a few others right
alex trebek he's not even american he's
canadian right
we'll adopt him for our own i think they
shoot the show in america so we'll call
him american
um so alex trebek tony dungy
is that it i think that's it that
they're they're the only two left
now um four from the daily wire again
attorney general william barr said on
thursday that federal law enforcement
officials have evidence that antifa and
other extremist groups have been
involved in instigating and
participating in acts of violence that
have rocked the nation for days
as riots had broken out following the
death of george floyd uh i i think we're
we're going to see a lot more about
there's a lot more to come out about
this i think
and what i really want to know are the
democrats and
high-profile people who have been
you know personally involved in
communicating with antifa and
coordinating with them i guarantee
there's
some of that stuff going on and this is
really important and we need to know
about antifa as a domestic
terrorist organization there's no
question about that but as i've been
saying all along we cannot let this
distract us
from we cannot solely scapegoat antifa
i've got no problem
with with criticizing antifa and
column domestic terrorist organization
arrest everybody involved in it if they
are a domestic terrorist organization
then you have no right to be involved
with them
you should all be arrested i'm all i'm
on board with that
but we cannot allow
here's what we really can't allow we
can't allow black lives matter
as an organization to scapegoat antifa
because black lives matter and antifa
are two two sides of the same coin
and i've been talking about this all
week there are even a lot of
conservatives who seem to want
to exonerate black lives matter and make
this all about antifa
we cannot do it black lives matter is a
an extremist organization
has a has a lengthy history of violence
and so this is also about them now we're
going to go to our daily cancellation
before we do you know where do you even
begin when you talk about all the things
that are happening
this year it's a lot to stay on top of
and stay educated on because the
left-wing media is just constantly
pushing their agenda without giving you
the real story that's why we here at
daily wire bring
we like to skip the mainstream narrative
to bring you both sides of the story so
right now go over to dailywire.com
subscribe get a daily wire membership
for 15 off using coupon code walsh
and if you join us as an all access
member you'll get two
glorious leftist tears tumblers because
you deserve the truth and cnn
isn't going to give that to you anytime
soon all right now for the daily
cancellation today is a nice book end of
our conversation to start the show
we're going to cancel tim wise now tim
wise calls himself an
anti-racism educator so you know this is
going to be good
and he was on cnn i think this was
yesterday and here's what tim wise had
to say
i think the the important thing for
white parents to keep in the front of
our mind
is that if black children in this
country are not allowed innocence and
childhood
without fear of being killed by police
or marginalized in some other way then
our children
don't deserve innocence if tamir rice
can be shot dead in a public park
playing with a toy gun something white
children do all over this country
every day without the same fear of being
shot if tamir rice can be killed then
white children need to be told at least
at the same age
if they can't be innocent we don't get
to be innocent and if we would keep that
in the front of our minds
then perhaps we would be able to hear
what black and brown folks are telling
us every day and have been for many
years
okay i have a migraine as a sudden onset
migraine um
now first of all
as this anti-racism educator tells
parents to be racist against their own
kids
a few points i think need to be made
number one
white children play with toy guns and
don't get shot by cops
that's true so do black children all
right tamir rice was a horrendous and
tragic situation and the reason we all
know about it and
know his name and remember it years
later is that it was
such a thankfully rare horrific event
so this idea that only white children
can play with toys without getting
killed by the cops is absurd
millions of white and black children
play with toys uh and are perfectly safe
in doing so number two
preserving preserving innocence all
right
is is something that parents and
communities
have to do primarily parents but
communities also can help
if a black child in the inner city has
been robbed of his innocence
it's not because of the police
it's not because of the systemic racism
it's not because of this the system
at all it's because his parents have
failed him
and his community has failed him
has failed to preserve that innocence
and it is true
in fact that many black children in the
inner city have had their innocence
robbed
absolutely but
um the thing is that probably wouldn't
have happened
if they had two married parents in the
home
the fatherless rate in the inner city is
like 80 percent if not more
so if they have two married parents in
the home especially a father present and
determined to preserve their innocence
and a community that was focused on
protecting its children
um then this wouldn't have wouldn't have
happened
many communities in the inner city do
not have that focus
and that again is not the fault of the
cops
speaking of scapegoats it's very easy to
scapegoat the cops it's easy to
scapegoat
scapegoat the government and there's
plenty of legitimate criticism
to be levied against those groups
but at the end of the day okay
um when you go to the inner city you're
gonna find
vast majority of kids do not have a
stable home life they don't even have a
dad in the home
and then you know you talk about their
innocence and then them not having
innocence
you're going to blame it on the police
now um and and also this problem of
children you know having their innocence
robbed is an enormous problem it's
widespread
i talk about it all the time it happens
everywhere it happens in the suburbs it
happens among white families in white
neighborhoods all the time
many white parents fail to provide their
children with guidance and protection
and next thing you know their
eight-year-old son is on pornhub looking
at hardcore porn right
in fact with some suburban white
families they go out of their way to
intentionally
destroy their children's innocence they
take them to you know drag
drag shows at the library so this is a
problem this is a
crisis level problem that i have talked
about many times across the entire
country and the robbing of innocence
from children
you know it can take different forms it
manifests itself in different ways in
different communities
but it happens across the board and but
it goes back to the parents
the parents not doing their jobs now
and and i say that if you are a parent
dead set on preserving your child's
innocence that's still going to be a
huge challenge because of the culture in
the society we live in
but the first line of defense is you as
parents
now number three to emphasize it is the
job of the parents primarily to to guard
and preserve a child's innocence
every child deserves innocence every
child has a right to it
if you take that away from your child
because other kids don't have it
that's no different than starving your
child because other kids
you know kids in ethiopia are starving
now if you want to instill in your child
a gratitude and appreciation for the
food
that he's provided because other kids
don't have food
that's a good thing i tell my kids that
all the time uh you know if kids are
gonna
aren't finishing their food on their
plate you tell them to be grateful for
the fact that they have food to finish
their food right that's a good thing to
tell kids
but you're not going to starve them
because other kids are starving
that would be deranged abusive insane
criminal and that's what tim wise is
advocating
i don't think i probably didn't need to
go 10 minutes explaining why
tim wise is wrong for saying that white
parents should intentionally rob their
kids innocence based on race i mean
we probably didn't need that lengthy
explanation but
uh i gave it to you anyway because
that's what i do here i state the
obvious this whole show could be called
stating the obvious the matt wall show
maybe that is what it should be called
i don't know um almost nothing that i
say is is
is really that revolutionary insightful
or impressive
um it's just that there are so many
maniacs in the world today
that we actually need to go over these
very basic common sense things
so we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody hope you have a great
weekend
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there